yes yet the walking dead well um welcome
back guys welcome back um a lot of [ __ ]
happened and [ __ ] will continue to
happen of course like a like we all know
it come to love okay your lovely
narrator is here okay okay let's check
this huh it looks like hamden it was i
oh jesus oh there's my man Kenny with
this biz peas always got my six been a
little [ __ ] and there's crazy Russell
[ __ ] owe me good I know we cut courts
easily here well we got to cut this core
and he's slowing us down there's chance
we get we gonna let him just get behind
sit here
ah yeah she was that shall we all know
why can't I just hold it [ __ ] no think
back hey look at you I'll betcha I'll
need to talk to me uh I need a [ __ ] not
now I need you to focus keep your
attention on the street ok sorry
house'll need his legs pretty bad I'm
fine you're not fine you need to rest he
needs to rest uh we need to keep moving
it's not safe to stop out here in the
open we need to keep moving you can rest
after we find a boat and get out on the
water I don't know how much longer he
can keep on like this no hablas you're
going to have to carry him or leave him
what no that's not an option ok baby
I've known you for all it 12 hours you
don't get to say we unless you mean just
you and him you know since this all
started I've seen the best come out of a
lot of people and the worst come out of
a lot of butter guess we know which side
you came down a little bit there you go
again we there is no we there's us and
there's you and your boyfriend is
slowing us down Krista Kenny's right
long can we stay out in the open the
more dangerous it is for all of us I'm
not leaving him no one's asking you to
we just got to keep moving all of us
silly birthday yeah I think you helped
him his leg looks really bad yeah you're
right Oh meet here give me y'all yes
what the hell [ __ ] Beldar maybe this
city's not so dead after a rush keep
moving no one's ringing that Bell it's
automatic on a timer why he's so angry
what kind of church bell goes off at
twenty past the hour shet how much
scratching head really trying to think
someone's up there are you sure I don't
see anything that [ __ ] I know what I
saw I'm telling you this someone up in
that bell tower someone alive I wrinkly
how are you I'd get out of hickory now I
thought you said that thing didn't work
she's such a [ __ ]
are you in the tower who is this is that
you up in the bell tower I love how big
his eyes get when he's like alarmed
there's gonna be a [ __ ] pop out little
fly [ __ ] the response
the hell was that someone trying to [ __ ]
with us sounded more like a warning ask
Not For Whom the Bell Tolls this guy is
what are you yammering all about a sub
cryptic not great it tolls for thee
money just so I can say the gamma what
is it feels like a real
okay we gotta get rid of those dudes hey
oh god damn it run follow me [ __ ] leader
Oh need
Kenny yeah I guess I'll be back little
too close don't you think I got your 6
brother no damn chicken [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
kill them
Russell is a ver to step in chess I know
it don't kill but it hurts
move your asses River streets right up
and that's not all we're gonna need I'll
give me a [ __ ] break wait he's in
trouble we gotta help them get out
there's no time we gotta go now oh I
love when they say go cuz then it's like
okay chest yeah you know I'll get the
door oh yes yes courtesy okay 00 talking
it Oh neat is dying you better put him
out of his misery take a booth do ya ah
yeah you've opened up your room you're
bleeding [ __ ] it's gonna get infected
we've got to get him inside clean him up
Kenny how's that dork i'm working on it
i'm working on it he like angry run
today won't be long before those things
outside figure out where we went you
know they can smell blood you see if i
press away hopper ok k planter time
let's see looks like something was
buried here oh really just a doghouse
now thirsty enough to drink that yet see
the shovel is never not useful mm-hmm
man to that sister okay let's see if
anything would be on the side nothing
nothing the way I movie put a bus do
that well let me check that dog mounting
real quick you bear up this grave don't
think I want to still digging up God
knows one until we find a way into that
house tours he's serious bro okay okay
then I'm just gonna use that one grid
tool you know the wind will be able to
bust through that I'm gonna [ __ ] this
guy up good a chick Jen about what
happened back there on the street I know
I don't know what happened I just froze
up hasn't that ever happen to you just
hear what I'm saying to you put that
girl in danger again it won't be
Walker's you have to worry about I hear
you think we can get in through one of
these windows man I don't think so
whoever owned this place had them all
barred up okay looks pretty solid like
Mike my shadow check things out like my
pillow and I poop out it's like solid
poopies okay
the wind will be able to bust do that we
have to shave with a bus do that Louie
and we'll be able to bust through that
no way we're gonna force that open now
without making a lot of noise at least
how's it coming found a way in yet doors
locked up tight too heavy to force it
without making a whole lot of noise
maybe there's a better way you hmm there
is I ain't seeing it think I'll go have
a look around okay okay let's take him a
peek around you know I'm saying okay
okay okay nothing up there nothing up
there dirt man damn man for hear
anything nope tree nope yeah stop right
now okay okay don't have to talk to
these people how's he looking I'm all
right you're not all right you've
reopened your wound is so negative lud
and god only knows what might have
gotten in there it could be infected it
could be no offense but you really need
to work on your bedside manner
she's just worried about you man don't
worry we're gonna get you fixed up in
Milltown eyes except when teens were
inside could be popping beep Lena okay
thanks man please go and help Kenny we
need to get him inside now come on sit
tight day going anywhere do you think
the dead people saw has come back here
are they going to find us no they didn't
see us we were too fast for I can still
hear them out there it sounds like
they're getting closer it's just
generation I don't feel safer when we're
inside the house hey nice shexy moving
like God where's she gone yeah she's
gonna be there ok now let's see there's
actually some word thing we could do now
no keep saying we have to talk making
any progress on that door the [ __ ] oh so
doghouse on their way I'm gonna be able
to bust do that what's this looks like
there's some kind of pet door here I
tried it already that's locked too who
the hell ever heard of a lock doggie
door I have my neighborhood one just
like that it's it's radio controlled dog
wears a collar with a chip in it so the
door only opens when the dog gets close
[ __ ] every day's a school day we got to
dig up that [ __ ] n all right so where's
the dog we all know where the dog is ok
we all know where the dog is gather out
kids gather round right to learn some
stuff in biology ok hey be careful
digging up dead things isn't what it
used to be you know what I mean [ __ ] I
wonder the zombie ducks
what's very down there I don't know TV
it's a [ __ ] body [ __ ] okay okay you
know nothing clin go over and sit with
Kristin over okay what I want to just do
what I say okay jaysus [ __ ] the [ __ ] out
with sit your ass down no smell most of
belong to someone oh yeah she be in here
kind of guys are gonna turn alive [ __ ]
can't get it off oh ok that is not cool
pretty I'm fine honey it's just the
smell are you sure you I said I'm fine
ok [ __ ] yeah well now that i got this
little collar gather out kids gather
round girls nothing yes god damn kenneth
only ape [ __ ] he's probably got a
massive hard or anything in there massa
Darla looks like it's been empty a while
morning to love it whatever you're gonna
do do it fast okay we see if I can reach
up in there be careful man that comes
out of jail it's no good I can't get it
here let me try I think I can she's a
trained
clip what do you see in there
good job Clem yeah way to go I did good
right yes you do yeah you that didn't
you dad can we maybe have this
conversation inside I like starting to
hurt like hell yeah just a seat so I was
a little noisy it just be crazy [ __ ]
be crazy looks okay from here everybody
in
oh sorry sorry no it's okay I'm good
feel better already just being off my
feet thanks babe
oh that's all you in the picture should
suck and cute it so when were you gonna
tell us about the radio to tell you what
that that it's working that there's
someone else on the other end of that
thing you didn't think that might have
been worth sharing a lot of this [ __ ] I
didn't know myself until it just started
working out there on the street so you
don't know who that voice was did you
hear me [ __ ] I know it gives a [ __ ]
about the damn radio I'm more worried
about whoever it was out there ringing
that Bell and bringing the dead down on
top of us it's like they didn't want us
to make it to the river what makes you
think it's not the same person whoever
was on the radio was close enough to see
us in the street and we didn't see
anyone else other than the guy in the
belt because that doesn't make a lick a
damn sense why would they bring out the
dead like that and then try to warn us
about it hmm no access damned if I know
maybe they were just trying to mess with
us wouldn't be the most screwed-up thing
i've seen these past few weeks i can
tell you whoever that was on the radio i
think they were trying to help us they
did warn us did name maybe you're right
but whoever it was they're watching us
following us and they don't want us to
know who they are this kid give any
explanation for that that would make me
feel better can you
yeah I'm with kidding yeah once it's
quieted down on sound we'll all head to
the river together do you suit
yourselves and I'm not gonna wait around
too long for someone else to grab up
those boats that's our ticket out of
here
place seems secure at least I'll feel
better when we know that for sure let me
see we need to check tell you to keep
with us we have to get rid of that girl
right there ken it's like everything we
you got down here Bannock sure you check
every duel understand Oh me okay slowing
us down ok so those are the people we
have to eliminate ok so can I helped
opens what if there's another lock door
I think you've been helpful enough for
one day kiddo why don't you just see if
krista know me you need anything okay ok
I like salmon this [ __ ] hang here Oh
cereal ok just like my mama's house I'll
leave that dog
no power take this dog fin and get have
you later I'm not that hungry besides I
need to finish check in the downstairs I
he turns his back on it like he's like
really like just against it I think
there's one at a cabinet wasn't there
yeah Walter
he's still get excuse the bursting
crying again
[ __ ] and cleaned out sick media water
nothing waters off its fact that i can't
get let's say let's see
must have stopped working a while ago
I'll take that whiskey whatever cleared
this place out live behind two bottles
of whiskey looks like someone didn't
have their priorities straight hey you
know loves his own jokes did I take it
okay probably not the best idea right
now ah to stay frosty how's it coming
yeah it's going great I guess what is
that looks expensive and heavy doubt any
looters would be able to hold that thing
too far
see here see here okay okay
not exactly my style
we just give this room and an ocular
pat-down real quick make sure
everything's safe you know I'm sad you
know okay nothing here so to examine
this stuff
yeah shut your LAPD yeah Jesus nothing
hardened in here okay
huh just a dog and eating a person to
tears
all clear in here you're not gonna check
that good oh I'm just checking safe
anxious then oh i thought i'm actually
looking for supplies and stuff why why
he's not taking anything
and
big door big Dora oh [ __ ] man [ __ ]
what what happened a mop get back as a
mom it's not just nothing a huge closet
door well please ain't got much we
should be okay here for a while at least
until the quiets down outside good thnx
m8 is he okay Jeff to the white peaceful
in his slim no but I'm really worried
his leg might have gotten infected don't
suppose you turned up any meds while you
were poking around just dog crew and
there's some whiskey in the back I wish
he could do was just after Clementine if
she knows who the man on her radio is
it's okay honey you can tell us who is
he what does he want
go here cliff that's okay you're not in
any trouble
it's just a friend I don't think he
wants to hurt us what has he been saying
to you what have you been saying to him
I told him I was trying to find my
parents and that they were in Savannah
he really seems nice I think he wants to
help me find them Clementine honey trust
me that's not what he wants he li li you
need to get up here now what's wrong
it's Kenny he's turned Oh
Kenny said he thought he heard something
up there went to go look he's up there I
can't get him to come down shades down
here looks like we're gonna have to kill
Kenny no talking fast Jesus ok ok um ok
look at my genes I'm going slow so i'm
gonna look at my my denim of spring 2013
limited edition run jimmy students suck
on this day oh sorry Kenny you okay man
for Jesus what the hell is that oh my
god
what the [ __ ] down looks like duck dhoni
it's just a kid what the hell happened
to him but there nothing on guessing mr.
be hot enough here starve to death Jesus
Christ I don't know if I can Lee
couldn't do it before can't do it now
before it was your side now it's just a
kid I need your help you can you go to
this romantic eight years turn sideways
know Justin that gap Oh God
here Brad Gill feel better so fingers on
each record I always do I don't know
that I can do with Lee yeah you can do
come on brah and I know that you can I
couldn't even help my own boy that was
your own flesh and blood no father could
have done that but you can help this boy
do what's right for him send him on his
way
I'm like I lost his son into life and
like lipman charity meant of each other
yes suck on the end of the gun that's
what we did on the streets make him
think foot well I did not hesitate we
should bury him no I did think this guy
I'll take care of it [ __ ] girls all
right now all the [ __ ] walkers are
gonna trying in here Hey look at the
white eyes you want to kiss i'm kennie
kiss [ __ ] hers you sicko Oh goodbye
little I'm like goodbye you see I'm
taken to dinner with us
is he gonna go in the dog thing to be
the same like it sucks on
if I so light
yeah that's putting the birdbath
into the Hall of the dog
you [ __ ] disgust
no Walter Walter
um
is this supposed to be like sad or
something
and look at that boy no more my barium
that was an all day just looking out
what the heck
no thanks
then I was watching me
she's thinking to marrying me now she's
like that's umbrella I need the cape
with my young and my bird i like it like
a little jacket down sick very um left 4
dead style oh yeah poor that [ __ ] i'll
pour that [ __ ] on look at one more time
cry crap on me
ok
all right oh [ __ ] yeah what you want hey
hey
who are you what the hell do you want
from us Lee what's going on bicha trust
me then I saw someone standing there by
the fix watching us a walker no too fast
took off like a bat of a hill when I
spotted him was it a man or a woman
didn't get a good enough look what does
it matter I'm wondering if it's the same
guy who's been following us the guy on
the radio yeah I'm fine I just had to
take a [ __ ] I'm fine what's all the
ruckus Lee saw someone watching us from
outside the gate what who I can't be
sure they ran off before he lives I
don't like this one bit not one bit me
either walkers are one thing but the
thought of someone out there actually
stalking us alright that's it we stuck
around here long enough it's time to get
back on track time to get down to the
river and find ourselves a boat I don't
know if Oh meads well enough to move yet
well he better get ready because i'm
going down to river street right now to
find a boat and as soon as she's ready
to go we are moving out we only check
the house to make sure it's secure we
didn't really toss the place we're low
on food water meds ammo we should make
sure there's nothing here we can use
before we move out will you search it if
you want I'm done with this house we
came to the city to find a boat and
that's just what I'm gonna do maybe it's
in such a bad idea to check the place I
said I'm done with this house Kenny your
trip involved it you be [ __ ] trippin
he's not the leader did we can do both
then you take one last look around a
place grab anything that looks useful
while me and Kenny go down to the river
to get us a boat wait can't I come my
mom and dad can't be far now maybe we
can look for them on the way to the
river
and kid right now but you promised we go
find them when we got here on the train
you promised I know I did sweet pea I
haven't forgotten but Savannah's more
dangerous than I thought it would be we
all need to stick together as a group
okay daylight's burnin gonna go grab my
gear then we'll head out come on Clem
let's go see if we'll meet needs
anything I do not like Oh Mia don't know
why so you're just gonna leave me on the
bench here yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ] no
offense but I'd feel safer if you stay
how am I supposed to not take offense to
that what am i a liability yes [ __ ]
huge libel 8 just great thanks a lot for
the vote of confidence kind of
announcers are being and you've got a
long way to go to earn yours back after
some of the stuff you people to freely
[ __ ] yeah yeah I feel you you know sorry
check out of context
hey so you want to talk about it about
what you know how did the attic no you
sure man I mean rivers right up ahead
Kenny use my browbone a [ __ ] trip and
Doug son of a [ __ ] that bastard's
[ __ ] with us again it's another trap
no listen that's not the same Bell as
before this one's further off whatever
it is it's gonna get the dead moving
over there
oh sure that those are good cat what the
hell is going on
he's exes to matically move in the [ __ ]
on the city it's crazy I don't know but
the person ringing that Bell might be
doing us a favor whatever man I find
whoever's doing that I'll wring their
mother [ __ ] bail for him good one
Kenny did you [ __ ] hear a pen let's
keep moving still nothing moving behind
us I think we're oh my god
Jesus there's gotta be a boat there's
gotta be
are you sure about that
we need to start thinking about a plan B
this is the plan it's the only one we've
got and you pissing on it in front of
everyone like you did back at the house
ain't exactly helping screw you I ain't
giving up that easy
this [ __ ] is Craig
[ __ ] I love this one might still be
salvageable
Kenny get a grip this boat is totally
fun oh ya know a lot about boats do you
tell you what if I ever need an expert
opinion on American history I'll be sure
to ask but how about you leave the
nautical [ __ ] to me
this [ __ ] is a loose cannon I'll
checked out you look further along the
waterfront maybe there's something at
the other end I don't think we should
split up too far we don't have to see
that telescope you can see all the way
along the waterfront from right here see
what you can find okay yeah Brzeski all
right guys I think we're gonna end it
right there cuz I got [ __ ] to tell you
know I got okay um yeah good times good
times we learned that Kenny is getting
more batshit crazy with his little pet
in the Attic um and yeah Crystal's a
[ __ ] as usual all right guys um thanks
for watching thanks for watching